in this segment we will look at the
famous example which goes posed by count
to be found a French naturalist back in
the 18th century and it marks the
beginning of a subject that is known as
the subject of geometric probability the
problem is pretty simple we have the
infinite plane and we draw lines that
are parallel to each other and there are
spaced apart D units so this distance
here is D and the same for all the other
lines we take a needle that has a
certain length L and we throw it at
random on the plane so the needle might
fall this way so that it doesn't cross
any line or it might fall this way so
that it ends up crossing one of the
lines if the needle is long enough it
might actually even end up crossing two
of the lines but we will make the
assumption that the length of the needle
is less than the distance between the
tool between two adjacent lines so that
we're going to have either this
configuration or that configuration so
in this setting were interested in the
question of how likely is it that the
needle is going to intersect one of the
lines if the needle is thrown completely
at random we will answer this question
and we will proceed as follows first we
need to model the experiment the
probabilistic experiment mathematically
that is we need to define an appropriate
sample space define some relevant random
variables choose an appropriate
probability law identify the event of
interest and then calculate let us see
what it takes to describe a typical
outcome of the experiment
suppose that the needle fell this way so
that the nearest line is the one above
and let us mark here the center of the
needle one quantity of interest is this
vertical distance between the
and the nearest line let us call this
quantity X we're using here in lowercase
X because we're dealing with the
numerical value in one particular
outcome of the experiment but we think
of this X as being the realization of a
certain random variable that we will
denote by capital X what else does it
take to describe the middle suppose that
the needle had fallen somewhere so that
it is at the same vertical distance from
the nearest line but it has an
orientation of this kind this
orientation compared to that one should
make a difference because when it falls
that way it's more likely that it's
going to cut the next line as opposed to
this case so the angle that the needle
is making with the parallel lines should
also be relevant so let us give a name
to that particular angle so let's extend
that line until it crosses one of the
lines and let us give a name to this
angle and call it theta so if I tell you
X and theta you know how far away the
needle is from the nearest line and at
what angle it is it looks like these are
two useful variables to describe the
outcome of the experiment so let us try
working with these so our model is going
to involve two random variables defined
the way we discuss it just just now what
is the range of these random variables
since we took X to be the distance from
the nearest line and the lines are D
units apart this means that X is going
to be somewhere between 0 and D over 2
how about theta so the needle makes two
angles with the parallel line it's this
angle
and the complementary one which one do
we take well we use the convention that
theta is defined as the acute angle that
the direction of the needle is making
with the lines so that theta will vary
over a range from zero to PI over two
and our sample space for the experiment
will be the set of all pairs of X and
theta that satisfy these two conditions
this will be the possible X's and Thetas
having defined the sample space next we
need to define a probability law at this
point we do not want to make any
arbitrary assumptions we only have the
words completely at random to go by but
what would these words mean we will
interpret them to mean that there are no
preferred x-values so that all X values
are in some sense equally likely so
we're going to assume that X is a
uniform random variable since it is
uniform it's going to be a constant over
this range and in order to integrate to
one that constant will have to be 2 over
D and we understand that the PDF of x is
0 outside that range
similarly for theta we do not want to
assume that some orientations are more
likely than other orientations so we
will again assume a uniform probability
distribution and therefore that PDF must
be equal to 2 over PI for Thetas over
this particular range so far we have
specified the marginal PDF of each one
of the two random variables how about
the joint PDF in order to have a
complete model we need to have a joint
PDF in our hands here we're going to
make the assumption that X and theta are
independent of each other and in that
case the joint PDF is determined by just
taking the product of the marginal PDFs
so the joint PDF is going to be equal to
4 divided by PI
times D by this point we have completely
specified a probabilistic model we have
made some assumptions which you might
even consider arbitrary but these
assumptions are reasonable attempt at
capturing the idea that the needle is
thrown completely at random this
completes the subjective part the
modeling part the next step is much more
streamlined there are not going to be
any choices
we just need to consider the event of
interest express it in terms of the
random variables that we have in our
hands and then use the probability model
that we have to calculate the
probability of this particular event so
let us identify the event of interest
when will the needle intersect the
nearest line this will depend on the
following we can look at the vertical
extent of the needle by vertical extent
I mean the following let's see how far
the needle goes in the vertical
direction which is the length of this
green segment here in this example the
vertical extent of the needle is less
than the distance from the next line and
we do not have an intersection if the
figure was something like this the
vertical extent of the needle would have
been that but X would have been just
this little segment the vertical extent
is bigger than X and the needle
intersects the line so we have an
intersection if and only if the vertical
extent which is this vertical green
segment is larger than the distance X or
equivalently if X
is less than the vertical extended so we
will have an intersection if X is less
than or equal to the vertical extent of
the needle now how big is this vertical
extent let's use some trigonometry here
this angle here is Theta so this angle
here is also theta here we have a right
triangle and the hypotenuse of this
triangle is L over 2 this angle is Theta
therefore this vertical segment is equal
to L over 2 times sine theta so this is
the geometrical condition that describes
the event that the needle intersects the
nearest line and all we need to do now
is to calculate the probability of this
event so here is what we have so far
this is the picture that we had before
but drawn in a somewhat nicer way this
is the joint PDF that we decided upon
and we wish to calculate the probability
of this particular event that X is less
than or equal to L over 2 sine theta how
do we calculate the probability the
probability of an event that has to do
with two random variables what we do is
we take the joint PDF which in our case
is 4 over PI D and integrated over the
set of X's and Thetas for which the PDF
is nonzero so it's only going to be over
X's and Thetas in those ranges and also
only for those X theta pairs for which
the event occurs so what are these pairs
this event can occur with any
choice of theta so theta is free to vary
from 0 up to PI over 2 how about X for
this event to occur X can be anything
that is non-negative as long as it is
less than or equal to this number so the
upper limit of this integration is going
to be L over 2 times sine theta and all
we need to do now is to evaluate this
double integral let's start with the
inner integral because we're just
integrating a constant the inner
integral evaluates to the quantity that
were integrating the constant that were
integrating which is 4 times pi D times
the length of the interval over which
were integrating which is L over 2 sine
theta and now we need to carry out the
outer integral let us pull out the
constants which is this 4 with is to
give us two we have 2l over PI D and
then the integral from 0 to PI over 2 of
sine theta now the integral of sine
theta is minus cosine theta and we need
to evaluate this at 0 and PI over 2 this
turns out to be equal to 1 so the final
result is 2l over PI D and this is the
final answer to the problem that we have
been considering and now a curious
thought suppose that you do not know
what the number pi is and all you have
in your hands is your floor lines drawn
on your floor and the needle and you do
know the length between adjacent lines
on your floor and you do know your
length of your needle how can you figure
out the number pi
take your needle throw it at random a
million times and count the frequency
with which the needle ends up crossing
the line if you believe that
probabilities can be interpreted as
frequencies the frequency that you
observe gives you a good estimate of
this probability so it gives you a good
estimate of this particular number and
if you know the length of your needle
and of the distance between the
different lines you can use the estimate
of that number to determine the value of
pi this is a so-called
Monte Carlo method which uses simulation
to evaluate experimentally the value in
this case of the constant pi of course
for pi we have much better ways of
calculating it but there are many
applications in engineering and in
physics where certain quantities are
hard to calculate but they can be
calculated using a trick of this kind by
simulation here's a typical situation
consider the unit cube and for
simplicity I'm only taking a cube in two
dimensions but in general think of the
unit cube in n dimensions which is an
object that has unit volume inside that
unit cube there is a complicated subset
which is described maybe by some very
complicated formulas and you want to
calculate the volume of this complicated
subset the description of the subset is
so complicated that using integration
multiple integrals and calculus is
practically impossible what can you do
what you can do is to start throwing at
random points inside that unit cube so
you throw points unfold inside some form
outside you count the frequency with
which the points happen to be inside
yourself and as long as you're throwing
the points uniformly over the cube
then the probability of your complicated
set is going to be the volume of that
set you estimate the probability by
Counting the frequency with which you
get points in that set and so by using
these observed frequencies you can
estimate the volume of a set something
that might be very difficult to do
through other numerical methods it turns
out that these days physicists and many
engineers use methods of this kind quite
often and in many important applications